[Music]
do
fun
do you want my mic
[Music]
all right
good evening friends
how are you
good
good hey it's really good to have you
here um
if you haven't noticed i am uh not
normally in this role
um
but uh yeah so we have several people
out uh this week um including this
person who's normally here kelly if
you're watching um man i hope i'm
living up to the expectations that you
normally set here um but yeah in in
light of that too is we have uh denise
mason here tonight who is yes
a long time friend of the table she's
the pastor of pleasant valley united
methodist church which if you don't know
that's this building
so
surprise here you go you're here um also
holy week is coming up uh really really
quickly surprisingly um
and so there's two services we want you
to know about our good friday service is
going to be a joint service with
pleasant valley united methodist church
on april 15th at 7 00 p.m
everybody say 7 p.m
7 p.m on april 15th on april 15. cool i
have emphasized it just as the notes
have said
um now easter sunday is april 17th we
will be meeting at blue
heron events venue um try to say that
five times fast uh that is a mouthful
blue heron events venue uh just down the
road here in saxi uh at 10 30 a.m so it
is in the morning don't forget that 10
30 a.m in the morning join us invite a
friend invite your family it's it's
going to be a really special service
a lot of people are putting in a lot of
heart and work and goodness into that so
we are excited to celebrate easter with
you
on that note uh why don't we go ahead
and stand and i'm going to pray for us
before we begin worship
so if you bow your heads with me
o almighty god
who pours out on all who desire it the
spirit of grace
and of prayer
deliver us when we draw near to you
from coldness of heart and wanderings of
mind
that with steadfast thoughts and kindled
affections we may worship you in spirit
and in truth
through jesus christ our lord amen
thanks jesse
we're gonna get started with worship and
you guys are already standing so
yay um
i feel like one of those people who are
like i feel like the words i spoke
yesterday seem contradictory to the
words i'm about to say right now but
last week i shared how i was irritated
going through the book of john and
frustrated with jesus's words and
confused and like why can't it just be
more clear
this week y'all i'm finding a lot of
peace in the mystery of god
and
sometimes it's better if we don't know
everything and just accepting that and
embracing it and you know being in awe
of this mysterious force and source of
love and life
who just
makes all things work together for good
for those who love him and i'm just
holding on to that and kind of grounding
myself in that and
um i hope that as we go through this set
together that you guys find yourselves
embracing that mysterious wonderful
beautiful creative love of god
he is just this unexplainable thing in
my life sometimes that i just wish i
could nail down with words but i can't
it's just sometimes too good and
sometimes too frustrating
and then other times too amazing you
know what i mean it's just it's so many
things
anyways join in with us you are welcome
here your voices sing out lift them up
so
am i going in and out
that's all right just sing out okay
because you might not be able here
all right
i don't think that one was working so
it's okay
all right
mel's gonna get us started
excited to be with
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all my
his soul
name
seem like
never before
oh my
soul
worship your
holy name
[Music]
your it's
again
whatever may pass and whatever lies
before me
let me be singing with me
[Applause]
[Music]
i worship your holy
your name is great and your heart is
high
for all your goodness i will keep
wanting
10 000 reasons for my heart to find
[Music]
bless the lord o my soul
i'll worship your holy name
[Music]
and on that day when my strength is
failing
[Music]
10 000 years
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh worship his holy name
seem like never before
oh my soul
i'll worship your
holy days
[Music]
so
sing lord of all creation
lord of o creation
of the water earth in the sky
the heavens are your tabernacle
glory to the lord on high
god
wonders god wonders beyond our galaxy
you are holy
holy
[Music]
love heaven
me
i will celebrate the life
then i stumble in the darkness
[Music]
the universe declares your majesty
you are holy
[Music]
beyond our galaxy
the universe declares your majesty
[Music]
lord of heaven
hallelujah
[Music]
[Applause]
god of wonders god wonders beyond our
galaxies
you are holy
a precious lord reveal your heart to me
father hold
me
the universe declares your majesty
you are holy
holy
[Music]
sing this if you know it
holy
holy holy
[Music]
my sun shall rise
holy
[Music]
shall praise my name in
earth and sky
and sea
[Music]
[Laughter]
i
ready
[Music]
we see god wonders beyond our galaxy
you are holy
holy
[Music]
precious lord reveal your heart to me
father
holy
[Music]
thank you jesus
you are our father
and you are also god of this universe
and we stand in the tension of those
the extremes of someone so very close to
us
and someone also
all encompassing
thank you for that mystery god
would you guys join us in the prayer of
the people and read this prayer aloud
with us and if you're joining us online
feel free to share in the comments as
well we would love for you to join in
for the city of saxi texi and for every
city and community and all of those who
live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan
for the injured and the suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed
the unemployed and the destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us
and so we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
jason
for the names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we've
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
he is jealous for me
love's like a hurricane
i am a tree
bending beneath
the weight of his wind and mercy
[Music]
when all of a sudden
i am unaware of these afflictions clips
by glory
i realize just how beautiful you are and
how great
affections are for me
adore
[Music]
how he loves us so
how he loves us
[Music]
don't do how he loves us
oh
how he loves us
go back to the verse he is jealous for
me
he is jealous for me
we love us like a hurricane and i am a
tree bending beneath
the weight of his reigns and mercy
when all the love is
[Applause]
[Music]
i realize just how beautiful you are and
how great your reflections
[Music]
oh
how he loves us
[Music]
oh
how he loves us
[Music]
loves us
his oh
and he is our pride
drawn to redemption by the grace in his
life
[Music]
i don't have time to maintain these
regrets
[Music]
oh
he loves us
how he loves us
[Music]
yeah he loves
us
[Music]
oh
how he loves us
[Music]
he
loves us
oh
how
he loves us oh
he loves
us
[Music]
yeah he
loves us
[Music]
yes
god you are with us
emmanuel
thank you for walking
each step with us
for not being afraid of our flaws or our
failures
because there's no shame from you god
there is only love
thank you for seeing the real us for
knowing
each one of us
so personally
and still loving us
we are grateful for the kind of god you
are
inviting us in making room for our
stories
making room for our wounds
[Music]
and continuing to heal us
to call us your own
to want us along on your journey
god keep creating in us that story
keep doing your good work in our hearts
keep making us more like you
help us to trust your work in your hand
in our life
your renewal your redemption
your acceptance
[Music]
give us ears to hear your voice
give us a heart that understands and
knows you
give us feet that will follow you
and help us to love this world around us
with your love
in jesus name
amen
thank you guys so much y'all can go
ahead and take a seat and turn to the
people around you say hello make them
feel welcome and then denise will get us
started with the message
well
thank you so much for having me back
again i cannot tell you how much it
means to me and him how much i love this
congregation i hope you know that you
all are wonderful you're always
warm and welcoming and i'm so
appreciative of of that thank you for
the opportunity to be here and thank you
brett if you're watching
brett helps me out a lot by preaching
for me when i'm gone so i'm so excited
to be able to do the same
but today i wanted to start with the
scripture lesson
taken from the gospel of saint luke it's
chapter 19 1 through 10 are the verses
hear now these words
jesus entered jericho and was passing
through it
a man was there named zacchaeus
he was a chief tax collector and he was
rich
he was trying to see who jesus was but
on account of the crowd he could not
because he was short in stature
so he ran ahead and climbed a sycamore
tree to see him because he was going to
pass that way
when jesus came to the place he looked
up and said to him
zacchaeus
hurry and come down for i must stay at
your house today
so he hurried down and was happy to
welcome him
all who saw it began to grumble and said
he has gone to be the guest of one who
was a sinner
zacchaeus stood there and said to the
lord look
half of my possessions lord i give to
the poor and if i've defrauded anyone of
anything i will pay back four times as
much.
then jesus said to him
today
salvation has come to this house
for he too
is a son of abraham
for the son of man came to seek out
and save the lost
this is god's word for us today would
you pray with me
come holy spirit
may the words of my mouth and the
meditations of our hearts be acceptable
in your sight
for you are our rock
and our redeemer
amen
okay so any of you that have been to
sunday school when you were a kid
probably remember zacchaeus was if you
know it zacchaeus was a wee little man
and a wee little man was he he climbed
up in the sycamore tree for the lord he
wanted to see
and when the savior passed that way he
looked up in that tree and he said
zacchaeus you come down for i'm coming
to your house except for i learned it my
mother was british i learned of color
i'm coming to your house for tea i was
telling you
that
the story of zacchaeus when i was a kid
it was one of my very favorite stories
and maybe it's because kids are just
naturally short
that we like the story of a wee little
man
a little person
if you were listening uh when i when i
was uh reading the scripture you will
have noticed that
though that there's something
interesting in this
his lack of stature
is not the first thing we hear about
zacchaeus is it
the first thing we hear about him is
that zacchaeus is a chief tax collector
and that he is very rich
now he hears that jesus is going to be
passing by he wants to see him but the
text says on account of the crowd he
could not because he was short in
stature
well zacchaeus seems determined to see
this man about whom there's been so much
talk so he runs on ahead and he climbs
up in a sycamore tree
so here he is
perched in this tree
waiting
and waiting and suddenly there he is
jesus
and when jesus gets to the tree he looks
up and he says rather strangely
zacchaeus
hurry down
i have to stay at your house today
well the people start grumbling
jesus has gone to eat at the house of a
tax collector a sinner can you believe
it
and then zacchaeus says i'll give away
half my possessions if i've gouged
anyone i'll pay them back four times
what i took
and jesus looks at him and says today
salvation has come to this house
now on the surface this is a great story
about jesus offering salvation to
someone who's a cheater
someone who makes money off the back of
others
see tax collectors at this time were
people that worked for the roman empire
they collected taxes for roman instead
of a salary you see they were allowed to
charge a percentage
on top of the tax that was owed
that was their salary
so
no one likes paying taxes
but imagine if your taxes were collected
by someone from the irs
and
that person adds a percentage on to what
you owe but here's the big thing
you're not really quite sure how much
you owe
how much you owed in the beginning you
don't really know
and the pr and so what the person adds
on well you're not sure what it is it's
just an arbitrary amount
so last year you paid 500 in taxes and
this year it's a thousand
you have no recourse
you have to pay
now can you imagine
how much you would despise the people
that came to collect your taxes
but here's jesus
offering redemption to someone who has
become rich through cheating
zacchaeus repents and offers not only to
give away half of what he has but paid
back four times
that's a great story of transformation
sinner to saint
but while it's a great story
one that speaks volumes a closer look at
this text reveals something quite
interesting
there's a lot more
to this story
than we might think
see as is always the case when reading
the bible we can't just pluck a story up
out of wherever it was and
just
start talking about it
we have to look at context context is
everything the context where it is
placed within the overall witness
is incredibly important if we're looking
to interpret
so this story if we look at it is placed
right before
jesus enters jerusalem it's in the
gospel of luke right before he enters
into jerusalem
jesus is on his final journey to the
great city and that
what awaits him there
in a week or so he's going to be
arrested he's going to be tried and he's
going to be crucified
at this moment however
while his teachings and his love and
acceptance of all people have infuriated
the sadducees and the pharisees well the
people
still love him
see they love him because he's on their
side he's on the side of the people that
the roman empire has pushed down
he's on the side of everyone who's been
made miserable he is on the side of the
common person so with this background
now let's look
into the story again
we're told that zacchaeus is a very rich
tax collector
in fact
he is a chief
tax collector
now go with me back to that place
okay and
just hearing that profession alone
makes it really clear that we don't like
him
we do not like him one bit because he is
that guy
he's that guy the one who's rich
because he's a cheater
i mean he's only rich really because he
stole it from us
just looking at him kind of makes me mad
and as he walks by we give him dirty
looks
we don't have clothes like that
i mean he only has those things because
he's a crook look at him
picture danny devito
fact picture danny devito in the suit
and in the role of a villain
what a mean man
and to top it all off he's really short
he's probably mean because he's so short
i mean isn't that always the way it is
look at napoleon
now the text tells us that zacchaeus was
trying to see who jesus was
but on account of the crowd he could not
because he was short in stature now
here's where it gets interesting
because we're told that zacchaeus ran
ahead and climbed up the sycamore tree
to see jesus
this verse is so full of meaning first
zacchaeus ran
in the first century a middle eastern
man running well they never did it
because if they had if they ran they had
to hitch up their tunic you see they
would have had to show
their legs
their bare legs
and in that culture well it was
humiliating it was shameful to show your
bare legs
and not only is he running
he's climbing a tree now imagine how
much more you can see when someone is
climbing a tree
and imagine how far you would have to
hitch up that tunic now why would
zacchaeus do this
run ahead and climb a tree
why didn't he just push his way to the
front of the crowd
maybe
because he couldn't
see the text says he was trying to see
jesus but on account of the crowd he
couldn't because he was short in stature
the word here is interesting because in
english his short stature seems to be
the problem
people were crowding around and he
couldn't see because he was too short
but the words in greek
indicate something a little different
they indicate that the crowd is the
problem
see he knows the crowd will not allow
him to see jesus he knows he's hated and
there's no way under the sun that
they're going to let him through
but he's heard some things about jesus
he's heard that jesus is different
and he wants to see if it's true
he is so hopeful so hopeful that in fact
he runs ahead maybe hoping to beat the
crowd but deep down he knows it's not
going to make any difference even if he
does
so he climbs a tree
now we tend to think of zacchaeus as
this cute little leprechaun
who is up in this tree and he's hanging
out on a limb looking for jesus
but the truth is if you know what a
sycamore tree is
it's a very full and leafy tree
if you're looking for a place to hide
a sycamore tree is the tree to climb
chances are that no one will ever know
you're there they cannot see you
see zacchaeus didn't want anyone to know
he was there
in the tree he's hidden no one can see
him
no one can push him out of the way no
one can give him dirty looks or make fun
of him
he can see jesus from there and remain
unnoticed by everybody else
now jesus comes into town and i'm sure
everyone is cheering and trying to shake
his hand or ask him a question but then
a funny thing happens
the text tells us that jesus gets to the
place where zacchaeus is hiding and he
looks up now can you imagine
that moment
being zacchaeus
i imagine that his heart is way up here
it's up in his throat is jesus going to
call him out is he going to shame him in
front of everybody
maybe he won't see me he thinks
i can imagine zacchaeus sort of
shrinking down hoping to remain
invisible but
jesus sees zacchaeus
and he doesn't even seem surprised does
he
he greets him like an old friend hey
zach
come on down hurry up
i'm staying at your house
well zacchaeus hurries down he's
thrilled to have jesus come to his house
but
the crowd
they're not that happy
can you imagine
we've been standing out in this hot sun
all day waiting to see jesus
and he comes into town and we're just
waiting for him to notice us
i washed my hair i put on clean clothes
i put out my sunday best
but jesus overlooks me and he tells this
horrible man this short little napoleon
that gouges us this crook
that shouldn't be even in the same place
as us to hurry down
he's going to his house
i can't believe it
i mean people are saying jesus is the
messiah the one who will save us but
he's going to that guy's house
this is the one they thought maybe pure
as god
but now he's doing something awfully
impure isn't he
something no good jew would do
he's going to stay with a chief sinner
the one guy in town who's universally
despised
not just me who thinks it
because notice that the text said all
who saw it begin
began to grumble all who saw it began to
grumble
it's not just the pharisees and the
sadducees that are mad now
this man has gone beyond the pale
because now it hits me
this isn't some religious law that he
decided to ignore he's going to the
house of someone we despise
someone who by all rights and purposes
should be run out of town
this is too much
now at this point zacchaeus has come
down he's standing there and noticing
the reaction of the crowd he could have
scurried off he could have scurried off
with jesus pleased his punch that he was
given the honor he could have rubbed it
in their faces
he chose me over you
but he doesn't
in fact he does something quite
remarkable
he stands there where people are over
towering over him on all sides and it
must have been intimidating at best and
terrifying
at worst
but he stands there and the text tells
us he tells jesus the truth
he tells jesus what
what he knows we won't even allow him to
say
he says look
i give half my possessions to the poor
and if i defraud anyone i would pay them
four times the amount i overcharged them
see the english translation of this
phrase is in the future tense it reads i
will give half of my possessions to the
poor and if i've defrauded anyone of
anything i will pay them back four times
as much
but the greek here is not
in the future tense
the present tense
i do this now
not in the future i already do this
present you see this turns this whole
story up on its head
how long is the key has done this
we don't know
if not i mean what happened
what we do know is that every person
believed him to be a sinner the bad guy
we do know that he was hated
he'd been written off as no good that
guy the one from whom there's no hope
the guy from the wrong side of the
tracks or the sleazy lawyer who sued us
he's that kid in school who was the
bully
the one we still think looks kind of
mean
he's the girl who talked behind our
backs all the time the one we would like
to see get her comeuppance
he's the guy in prison for a violent
crime the alcoholic who ruined the lives
of so many the list goes on and on and
on but you know who he
is he's that guy
and all of a sudden that guy is telling
jesus what
he's changed
he's not who we think he is
and jesus is buying it
because he looks at the crowd and he
says today salvation has come to this
house because he too is a son of abraham
why
why would he say that about this guy
do you see here how the tide is changing
do you see now why it was so easy to
yell crucify him
just a week or so later
see the crowd
believed that zacchaeus had lost his
right to call himself the son of abraham
in their eyes you see he was a traitor
he was a crook but jesus
sees zacchaeus's
heart and jesus does what jesus always
does
he reconciles
he restores those who are rejected by
society and
challenges our long-held prejudices and
beliefs jesus brings those who are on
the outside
inside
when jesus said
salvation has come to this house because
he too was the son of abraham what he
really was saying here is that zacchaeus
and everyone who lived under his roof
are welcomed back into the community
they're welcomed back into the community
of god's people from which they had been
excluded
jesus calls zacchaeus down from the tree
smack dab into the middle of the
community and he declares the man saved
he names him a son he restores him to
the people
now i got to tell you when i first
started looking at this story reading
the greek word for word with english
well i did not like it
i like the old ziki as the wee little
man the one who was transformed by jesus
the one who needed to be made right
the one who needed to be saved needed to
be turned around because if zacchaeus
isn't the bad guy
what's the point of the story
this zacchaeus makes no sense
until i stopped to think about it
stopped to pray and stopped to look in
the mirror
and i realized that the reason i didn't
like it
was because i'm one of the crowd
i'm one of the people who would rather
not accept that guy
rather not accept that he might be not
what i think
i realized
that just like them i am so sure of my
own goodness
because i am so sure of somebody else's
badness
i like so many people find it easier to
categorize people
you think i know who they are and what
their story is based on stereotype
to judge their character by whom i
suppose them to be
i wanted zacchaeus to be the bad guy
because if zacchaeus is the bad guy i
can remain secure in my place
i can remain self-righteous
i'm okay
it's him who's not
jesus says
for the son of man came to seek the lost
or seek out
and save the lost
did you notice how zacchaeus never
repented in this story
did you notice how jesus never said one
thing about your sins are forgiven
why not
maybe
because it wasn't zacchaeus
who was lost
maybe
just maybe it could be those of us in
the crowd
who are lost
but my friends
in this story there's still good news
even for us
you see because jesus is looking for us
just like he looked for zacchaeus he's
waiting for us to realize that we need
him
just like that guy needs him
he's waiting for us
to do that what he which he called us to
do
love
listen
to that guy's story
to that woman's story
hear who they really are
listen with open hearts
see if we do we might be really
surprised
to find jesus there
waiting
to come and stay with us
too
see this story is is one of good news
for all of us who may be trying to live
down our pasts
all of us who might have made mistakes
in life and feel like we're always going
to be paying for them
this story is good news for all those
who are on the outside looking in
wishing and hoping that somebody would
see them for who they really are
someone would want to come back to their
house
someone would love them
despite what they may have done
the savior sees
our hearts
mine
and yours
jesus is looking for you
no matter where you are
no matter how hidden you may be
jesus is looking to restore you bring
you back into the circle
and he's looking for us
to draw that circle wider
and that's the best news ever isn't it
amen would you pray with me
loving god
we freely admit that
we really like being the ones on top
we like being the people who
are in
god help us to draw our circle wider
help us to listen help us to see help us
to hear
of people
listen to their stories
god help us
to love
love without limits
it's in the name of jesus
the christ that we pray
amen
so amazed that you guys are doing
communion every week this is
it touches my heart and i'm so glad
um
i am supposed to go right into this am i
not okay good i just want to check
i as a methodist pastor i do communion
just a little bit differently but let me
just tell you it's the same thing
so
this is the table
this is the table not of the
church but of jesus christ
it is made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more
so come
you who have much faith in you who have
little
you who have been here often and you
have not been here long
you have tried to follow but
and you have hate failed come
because you see it's the lord that
invites you not me
and it's his will
that those who want him should meet him
here at the table
so lift up your hearts and give thanks
to god
it is a right and good and joyful thing
always and everywhere to give thanks to
you god father son and holy spirit from
the rising of the sun to its setting
your name is praised among all people
therefore we praise you
joining with all people on earth and all
the company of heaven who will forever
sing to the glory of your name holy holy
holy lord
god of power and might heaven and earth
are full of your glory
hosanna in the highest
blessed is the one who comes in the name
of the lord hosanna
in the highest
holy are you o god and blessed is your
son jesus christ
your spirit anointed him to preach good
news to the poor to proclaim release to
the captives and recovery of sight to
the blind
to set at liberty those who are
oppressed and to announce that the time
had come when you would save your people
jesus healed the sick
he fed the hungry
and he ate with sinners
by the baptism of his suffering death
and resurrection you gave birth to your
church
and you delivered us from slavery to sin
and death made with us a new covenant by
water
and the spirit
on the night in which jesus was handed
over he had a meal with his friends
and he took a loaf of bread and he after
giving thanks to god he broke it and
gave it to his disciples and he said
take and eat this is my body which is
given for you do this in remembrance of
me
and after supper he took the cup
and after giving thanks he gave it to
them and said drink from this all of you
for this is my blood of the new covenant
which is shed for you and for many for
the forgiveness of sins whenever you
drink it remember me
oh god we pray that you would pour out
your holy spirit on us gathered here
and on these gifts
that in the breaking of this bread and
the drinking of this wine we may know
the presence of the living christ
transform us god
transform us so that we can see with
jesus's eyes we can hear with jesus's
ears speak with jesus's mouth
renew us so that we can be the body of
christ in this world proclaiming the
good news of god's reign until christ
comes in final victory
and we feast at your table forever
amen
my friends come to the table
all is ready
come
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
with all the poor and powerless
and all the lost lonely
with all the thieves who come confess
know that you
are holy
[Music]
and know that you
are holy
you know
we'll
sing out hallelujah
in a
will cry out hallelujah
[Music]
all the hearts who are content
and all who feel and worthy
[Music]
know that you are
[Applause]
[Music]
we
through
[Music]
go on and scream it from the mountain
go on and tell it to the master
[Music]
that
[Applause]
you guys stand and sing that with us
shout it out
[Music]
go on and tell me
is
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
go on and tell it to the blind
shout
it
go on and scream it from the mountain
[Music]
go on and tell it to the masses
that he is
[Music]
how
we
will
cry
[Music]
denise thank you so much
for tonight
you know there there's something that
happens and brett has talked about this
before but when we read biblical stories
we start to
put ourselves in the places of the
characters right and so
you know a lot of us may easily put
ourselves in the crowd like yep i am one
of the crowd people but
you know i also
was just getting this sense of like
[Music]
man there might be several people in
here or online who are still hiding in
the sycamore tree thinking that they're
not seen
so i really really want to make sure
that you know that jesus sees you
and that it is a beautiful thing that in
our faith and our savior we don't have
to hide anymore
[Music]
so no matter where you see yourself in
that story no matter how you relate
salvation has come to this house today
[Music]
and now i transition into the stuff i'm
super good at
um if you feel so led to give we have
two ways you can do that you can do that
either online or we have a small box in
the back that you can give through as
well
also if you are new um or are just
starting out here a visitor either here
or online if you're visiting online um
you know we would love to get to know
you better to hear your story and so if
you wouldn't mind filling out
one of the welcome cards and placing
them on the back table that will help us
uh know that
that you are here and that we want to
get to know you um so in in that
uh where we're at right now is i'm going
to give you a benediction so if you'd
like to open your hands to receive this
uh
you may do that
the lord bless you
and keep you
the lord make his face to shine upon you
and be gracious to you
the lord turn his face to you and grant
you peace
now and forevermore
amen
[Music]